now I've given you a whole bunch of
functions that are defined by two
different equations at two different
places and I will mention that this is
by far this particular pair of
restrictions X is negative and then X is
positive that's my father most common
one that you will means but it's not the
only one and you just have to look down
the page to see the restrictions can be
anywhere you want them to be okay and
you'll get quite a different graph so
let's have a look at this thing you
start I tend to go from left to right
hey what - X and what does 1 minus X
look like I have an intercept at 1 ok
and it's minus X so it's increasing or
decreasing decreasing rates going down
it's going down now this is only defined
for X is less than 0 okay so what I've
really got is this part of the graph
did you see that so far so good
now just like over here in this example
by the way I tend to leave my endpoints
until the end right that was intentional
anyway I'll do my endpoints at the end
so I'm just gonna leave that with no
hollow or filled sac or anything ok now
I've gone from the left I'm gonna move
on to the right it's an x squared plus 1
that's a brother and it's been shifted
vertically up so it also has to label it
also has a y-intercept of 1 this is nice
and neat okay so therefore this is the
shape that we're getting now when you
have a look at this ok
what you've got is this point x equals 0
where it switches over ok but because at
the point of switchover right the Y
value of this and the Y value of this
they match they coincide right so even
though it changes it transitions there
are no discontinuities you see that
holes right it
well smoothly is maybe not the right
word because if you know it doesn't it
doesn't smoothly do this but there's no
break is no break I can draw this whole
thing and never lift up my parent
right so there are no discontinuities on
this graph there was a change though
okay now it's up to you probably on the
safe side to put on like there is a
point where it changes so you can just
like label that circle cuz that's what
it is but because they were nice
discontinuities I have no problem with
it having no filled circle you can just
go from one to the other
there are two pastors so just like with
absolute value which by the way is
another example of a piecemeal function
absolute value functions are by
definition piecemeal I'm gonna label
each of the brunches and y equals x
squared and I have my domains listed up
okay the question I asked to add on to
this was what's the range of this
function domain to be boring
what's the range of this thing okay yeah
y can hit it one the carconi low up
right so therefore my range is y is
greater than or equal to one if you want
to include it for completeness sake you
can say that the domain is either all
real X but you're gonna say that so many
times you're going to get sick of us so
you can write the symbols if you like
and X a curvy funny-looking e
it's actually an epsilon if you're
curious Greek and then that
double-barrelled are that showed up in
the fall which stands for real right so
this means X is anything in the set of
real numbers all right all real values